et on passe à la situation sanitaire en
france avec cette légère embellie
19 1683 cas enregistrés en un vous on
est donc passé sous la barre des 20000
mais cela n'était pas arrivé depuis le
mois de juillet pas de quoi se réjouir
pour autant en conférence de presse hier
soir le ministre de la santé a évoqué
des taux d'incidence inégalée référence
au département des bouches du rhône mais
surtout à la martinique et à la
guadeloupe et deux départements
antillais sont ceux qui comptent
aujourd'hui le plus de patients
hospitalisés avec 11% du total national
olivier ferrand qui ne cesse d'appeler à
la vaccination c'est elle qui selon le
ministre a permis d'éviter le pire cet
été si
je le dis et la firme devant vous qui
nous n'avions pas pu compter sur un
vaccin si nous n'avions pas mener une
vaste campagne de vaccination de toute
la population vaccinable c'est-à-dire
âgés de 12 ans et plus la quatrième
vague aurait pu être la pire des vagues
que nous ayons connue elle aurait pu
entraîner des dizaines de millier de
contaminations supplémentaires chaque
jour des cas graves en masse parce que
le virus plus contagieux peut se
diffuser à une vitesse folle et que nos
hôpitaux auraient pu être débordés en
quelques semaines nous contraignant un
nouveau confinement au coeur de l'été